which leads us into another basketball
story basketball star Kevin Love is
drawing a new attention to mental health
a problem for many Americans practicing
social distancing of course because of
the corona virus of pandemic one in five
American adults experiences some form of
mental illness each year the five-time
NBA all-star has a history of anxiety
depression and panic attacks and he's
become a spokesman on the issue he joins
us from his home in Cleveland Kevin Love
good morning thanks so much for being
with us thanks for having me I
appreciate it you donated $100,000 to
arena workers and several other players
have followed suit why was it important
for you to make that gesture just
understanding that this is gonna be such
a tough time to navigate it was actually
the Thursday morning after Adam silver
our Commissioner had postponed the
season and I was just thinking about you
know how these people are so much a part
of my story our story as NBA players we
see them at least 41 games home games
out of the year as well as other events
and these are these are people that you
start to develop a first-name basis with
the first-name relationship with people
that you know I've been in Cleveland now
six years who I see every time coming
into the game I'm giving them a bump
I'm asking them how their family is so
just knowing that this is such a tough
time than that navigate it's gonna be
such a stressful time anxiety ridden and
just the fear of unknown is gonna be
there so much I was just thinking about
all that stuff and thought it'd be great
to take care of the people who have been
taking care of me and supporting me and
and the Cavs organization for so long so
you know decided to you know donate to
them the arena workers some most of them
I feel like are living paycheck to
paycheck not knowing when food's gonna
be put on the table if they're going to
be able to take care of their families
so I thought it was super very important
to take care of them and then you saw
the Cavs stepped up and
you know said that they would pay the
organization said that they would pay
for all the games you know that that
aren't going to go on a lot of the
events that aren't going to go on and
then you saw different players stepping
up and and and doing the same thing or
donating meals you know committing money
to the nurses and the doctors and
several different hospitals so it just
kind of took on a life of its own and I
was incredibly happy to see other
players step up and do something similar
it was it was really cool to see that I
think so - Kevin first let's say Bravo
to you number one that you know the
workers names a lot of players don't but
you do
and the fact that they saw what you did
and they followed your lead honestly I
think it says something about who you
are as a person as a man and how you
live your life so Bravo Bravo to you on
that you've also been so outspoken about
your own I mean that you've been so
outspoken about your own mental health
issues and your own anxieties how have
you been coping during this time for me
just stay in active and making sure that
I have a routine so much of the time
when that has taken away from me I think
just by nature being a basketball player
I'm so used to having that routine so
making sure I'm getting up early I'm
getting the proper nutrition I'm taking
care of my body so physically taking
care of my body and then just
understanding what my core competencies
are and my my pillars in my life like
always working on my relationships
checking in with with friends and family
making sure that I'm you know while I'm
distancing social distancing I'm not
isolating myself I'm reaching out to my
family friends doing constant
communication because the device is here
you know so even if it's virtually just
staying in touch with everybody I'm
making sure that I'm doing that but just
continuing to move thankfully I have a
dog that forces me to get outside so
yeah things like that yeah that
certainly helps Kevin you know I tell
you what you'd have to be made of stone
to not be feeling a little bit of
anxiety a little bit of sadness right
now so what's your messy
to people who may be struggling with
this cataclysmic event we're all facing
yeah I think it's like I said earlier an
incredibly tough time to to navigate and
I would say my message would just be
it's it's it's normal to feel this way
the only way we're gonna get through it
is together I've said you know since
this you know started happening and we
were having to you know isolate
ourselves and quarantine that it's
normal to feel this way and the only way
we're gonna get out of this is together
like you know human beings are so
resilient and we will get through this
and I think you know the worst thing
that can happen is if we come out of
this unchanged we have to be able to
change and be there for each other and
be better so I do think there will be a
lot of great things that that come out
of this we may not be able to see it
right now and so much is changing every
single day and we don't know what life
is going to look like after this let
alone the mental health of a lot of
people coming out of this but nothing
nothing unites us like the common and
the same enemy so I would say just can
we continue to commit to that sense of
community and know that everybody's
going through something at this point
and at this time so just behind and and
take care of the next man and take care
of the next woman Kevin Love mr. Kevin
Love amen to that thank you very much
and that is one cool piece of barnwood
behind you thank you for being here